之前我們開始了解今天影片
我們要講一個很常理的問題
我聽到責任
是你一直在看一邊
就讓你去看一邊的投資
去看一邊的投資
看看這一個圖案
我們有一個投資的投資
我們看一看一看
再看一看一看一看
現在我們走 short
我們走 short
因為我們走 short
我們要看我們會的狀況, right?
我們都說我們會把狀況下的狀況。
我們看我們現在的狀況。
就像這樣,你會被狀況的狀況。
就讓狀況做什麼?
我們看我們什麼。
我們看我們這個狀況。
我們看我們這條狀況,
這條狀況會被狀況下的狀況。
但你會被狀況下的狀況。
但你被狀況下的狀況。
就算了狀況下的狀況。
我问你这个问题是什么我开始经历了在我当中的几乎
我当中的几乎是因为我开始的几乎
因为我几乎不几乎的几乎
我没有买到几乎的几乎
我只是在几乎的几乎
之前是否会有试图的几乎
现在我被我告诉你
这个指数我将会让你用在这个视频
和我用这个指数
会让你使用这个指数
比这个指数多像这个
看一看
这里是一个比较的
你看到我们的同样的同样
同样的同样的同样
在这个表面中有一个药物费中方法有一个药物费的相互费中方法
但几乎费的相当方法是用一个指导举的方法
我会给你用一个人用一个比例来看
在这个表面前的方法有什么来说
我们的新的高价值
像你能看到一样的药物费中方法
我们可以用一个执行的几乎费中方法
你会给你费的手法
用一个比例来看
我们有点多多余因为我们的比例来看
我们将来据到一个比例来看
用一个指导举的方法
我会给你用这个颈告和你用这个试试
因為那我們沒有停止到的
而這個市場的市場
而是在這裏面的
我們在這裏面的
我們在1.5-1%的
優惠優惠
從這裏面的
到這裏面的
所以,我已經被
我已經被困難了
尤其在這裏面的
開始的時候
而且,當中有辦法
不停止到的
以後,你會有
贏和贏的
在這裏面的
有辦法
有機會
被判斷了
市場裡的不準確或因為你的止落太多閒的不準確
而使用這種坊打破的不準確
我會不會用這個指定的指定
於這個調查過後
我們會用這個指定方式
方式使用這個指定
融合這個指定的資料
給自己一個得到的敗
這並非我最喜歡的指定
而且我用這個指定
每次次我用的指定
所以我會正在分享
你如何使用它,如何使用它,更加速度,更加速度,
所以, what is this mysterious indicator that can help you avoid barely being stopped out
before the market heads to your initial targets? It is called the ATR or Average True Range
我每次的投擎选招选择
我们将说什么的当铁锁吻
为你需要 再做事
又不足了
一详之中的选招选择
主要是从这条捏的
而言之为 这一章是你领地上设处
当铁桌上看到的液换线
是运动和莲运动
而是由于这个投擎的设计
這個計劃, since 2018 on the dollar Canada, produced 31 opportunities
11 of those opportunities were losing trades
20 of those opportunities were winning trades
meaning that this strategy since 2018 until today's date on the dollar Canada
produced a 65% winning percentage
so make sure to stick around until the end of the video
to learn this exact strategy that will help you when trading around false breakouts
但是現在我們現在進入了什麼是
ATR的指定
開始了
ATR是名字
這支指定是
這支指定的
14張紙
在一個個月的確
和幅度的確
它有一個關於14的確
你能夠改變
如果你想要的
十張紙
你能夠做的
如果你想要的
五張紙
不重要
我保持了
我看了一张的数据,我看了一张的数据,
我看了一张的数据,在一张数据,
在一张数据,现在,现在,你知了一张,
为了我们需要它?
因为每个数据,它有一个不同的数据,
它是一种据,在一张数据,在一张数据,
我们现在有一个ATR,
如果你看到一张,我会把这张数据,
这就是122pips
所以,Pound New Zealand现在现在
有一个ATR,或者是122pips
那就是最后14天的额红额
现在我们在这四天的额红额
在这四天的额红额上
是122pips
现在我们来说
一个不同的额红额
不太多
像是Canada Swiss
Canada Swiss
现在的额红额红额现在的额红额红额只有34pips所以我們要知道我们的线只移动了14线或者是我们的线只移动了
如果我们的线只移动了
我们的线只移动了
它看起来的线只移动了
你先说你一开始购买
and you use a 10 pip above the entry candle as every single time you place a trade as your stop loss
so you would say okay here's my 10 pips 28 that would be 38 and i'd be looking let's say you're
just looking for a one-to-one to keep it simple do you think that this 10 pip stop loss is going
to work just as well on the pound new zealand as it does here on the canada swiss if the canada
the Swiss is only moving at an average of 35 pips per candle and the pound New Zealand
is moving at 122 pips every time a candle is printed.
Do you think you're going to be stopped out a little more often here on the pound New
Zealand?
Yes you are and that's why we need to know the average true range of every single currency
pair we're trading.
Depending on the currency pair you're trading your stop loss may need to be larger or smaller
and in a very similar way it depends on the time frame as well if you have a 10 pip stop loss on
the 15 minute time frame do you think that same 10 pip stop loss is going to work on the daily
time frame when the daily chart has an average of 378 pips per candle while the 15 minute only has
an average of 26 pips per candle and you can see that again by looking right up here of course the
答案是不,你必须要知道那些
你必须要知道那些
我用每次的一天我放在止损
那是为了我用的ATR指定
为了我的止损
是因为每个股票会有
一样的一样移动
每个时间移动
每个时间移动的一样移动
所以你必须要加上那些
到你的止损
以为准备的失败
你准备的失败
不一定会准备的失败
但这会会准备准备
准备的失败
然后就会准备的失败
你所想的连败
现在知道了解的ATR是
我们需要的失败
我们将用这些失败
准备的失败
不备的失败的失败
让你再次用这个ATR来说
好,现在我们来说
你能够用这个ATR来说
能够用这个ATR来说
另外一个原因
你需要一个估值
来说是因为
不同的变化
在这个ATR来说
例如,在这个ATR来说
我们的这个ATR来说
你认为10pip的
10pip的这些ATR来说
你会被捏捏了
你会被换了一些新增加的股息
如果你有没有用这种股息的股息
你会被换了一种股息
这是用一个股息的股息
以为股息的股息
从股息的股息
在股息的股息
在股息的股息的股息
或不同的股息
现在是我们的股息
是在股息的股息
我会说你用TradingView,因为它是用的
我用的使用
所以在TradingView,你去看,是一种的一种
但是如果你想要做的,你需要做一个
一种做法,你需要做一个
几乎的几乎是在这边的几乎
按照,它会在几乎的几乎
几乎的几乎,现在,我们就在几乎
几乎几乎,到这里的几乎
then you will see right here we have a number that number is 70 at the moment that means that
currently on this market the ATR is 70 you can also see that if you look over here on the right
hand side of the screen right here at the side of the indicator I personally choose to look over
here but it's completely up to you that number again is current ATR the current average true
RANGE的$1CANDA在4HOURCHART是70PPS
所以那意思是在前14CANDLES
70PPS是映了AVERAGE
如果你想用这个给你做的
是温度了
CANDLE你将在ATR4BPS
如果我温度这个颜色椅子
我能看到的CANDLE
你能看到AVERAGETRU RANGE是22PPS
so if I hover over a candle the previous candle is 18.5 pips the previous candle before that is
18.6 pips hovering over a candle is how you use this indicator in backtesting but in order to use it
to place your stop-loss the way that I personally use this indicator placing a stop-loss is if I had an entry
right here
let's say on this
这张说明了
这张比喻的
这里的符词
这张是这样的
门看来的领团
如果我先得到那种
我需要我的身边
现在我将用了
说说我会用了
说我会用了
看来我会用了
不然而我会不做这
不然而会用了我将会用了这张嘴巴摆到这个所以这就会有82-83283pipsand that ends up being stopped out a rookie trader may say, okay, I'm going to place a stop loss 10 pips below this low. So that would be 82, 83 pips. And that ends up being stopped out.
Let's say we have a two to one risk reward.
Again, just keeping it simple.
That would end up being stopped out, right?
The difference would be I would hover over my entry candle
in order to actually use the ATR indicator
to place a stop loss.
I would hover over my entry candle
showing me that the dollar Canada on this candle
has an ATR of 80 pips.
With that being the case,
I wouldn't be placing a 10 pip stop loss
below my entry candle
or below this swing low
which is where my stop loss is going right now
that means if I had an 80 pip stop loss
I would use that value of 80 pips
under my swing low
or my entry candle
depending on which one was lower
the previous swing low though
at the entry being right here
is this entry candle
so I would put a stop loss at 80 pips below that candle
that means
that we would have a stop loss of 153 pips
是,你有一个大小的独乱
但那又是一个原因
你会想要留意的
并且有这个小小的独乱
因为你会有这个小小小的独乱
所以,那会有一个独乱的独乱
就像那样
然后,一二一的独乱
会被判断
因为我们用了独乱
正常用了一种独乱的独乱
所以,我们会被看了
是,你再次看了
是,你会有什么独乱的独乱
OK, so let's say we have an entry on this big close above candle here
We would look at this as our entry
If whatever entry you're using is totally fine
I'm just trying to show you how to place a stop loss using the ATR
You would then want to hover over that candle
When you're hovering over that candle
Look at the top left side of the screen
I'll circle it for you
The ATR is 67 right now
So you would put a 67 pip stop loss below the previous swing low
That's exactly how I use the ATR indicator
in order to place better stop losses that are less likely to be hit by highly volatile markets
or by different currency pairs that have higher averages in terms of the candles they print
or in different time frames for instance the 15 versus the daily this is how i use it so the trade
setup here if i have my profit taking tool would look like this we talked about our big green
candle as our entry the atr of that candle is 68 pips 186 plus 68 is 254 so we would have a 254 pip
stop loss and that's how you would set your stop again you set your targets accordingly it doesn't
two to one risk reward whatever kind of target you want this is just me showing you how to use
an atr indicator in order to place stop losses that keep you out of these whip saws and keep
you from being stop hunted by placing your stop loss a little further away or even a little
closer at times depending on the volatility of a certain market at a certain time depending on the
volatility of all markets at that time and on a certain time frame you do so by looking at the
average range of your entry candle using that amount that average true range amount below
the swing low on a buy trade or above the swing high on a sell trade in order to maximize your
能力去购买那购买
不过一失败的购买
那是用于ATR的方法
要求做了一失败的方法
不过一失败的方法
我现在就会做了一种方法
用于ATR的方法
用于购买的方法
给你做了一种方法
让它们有盾的方法
从2018年到现在
所以就先去那一步了,就先去那一步了
好了,就先到那一步了
这一步了,就先去那一步了
一步了解的一步了
我会做一个试图的试图
但现在,就先去那一步了
这一步了,就先去换了一步了
什么是一步了?
一步了一步了,就像这样一步了
如果我们看来,我们有一个高的高度
我们有一个高度的高度
指令 to breakout traders
就是指出了就去 short
在这期盘上
但总是这个问题的
但是不是这样
连路上的停止
因为这些改变了
就是这些盘子的确实做出了
这签是什么
刘的解释
对可以明白
什么是什么
所谓的
随的达
这些是什么
我们正在旁边的
需要这些
随准的随移
随的随意
就是我
就给你一个
很简单的解释
什么是随意
for this example a swing high is a high that was preceded by at least two lower highs and followed
by at least two lower highs that would be a swing high a swing low would need to be preceded by two
higher lows and have at least two higher lows after it so that would be a swing low that's
what we're looking for initially with this strategy after we find a swing high and a swing low we are
我们来坐一看到顺忌的感觉
比如是因为有限的那个高峰
在这边的课程中
这些使用是个上高峰
是一个高峰的高峰
在这回合我们来看了
它会有观光的高峰
我们会在这一看好峰的紅色
这就是回到我们加低红色的线
我们这个鞭的保持有限
我们做到我们的位置
我们是在看我们的高峰和中
to do a swing low for a bearish trade
we know what a swing low is
it's a low preceded by 2 higher lowsand followed by 2 higher lowsso we're waiting on a break out of a level like thatwe have this break outthis break out candle这一判写上的重点继续 两个高级大级长所以我们再来一个估计感的绝区我们呈现这个估计感这个估计感能噢级高原酱的频道
估计感能量
是非常大的热心
在并且十分估计感能量
是否估计感上的
这个绝区的磯提长
所以我们将开键估面
有什么关系感的
ATR上为 79万人的推动
我们的问题们需要
由于公开
to the low of this breakout candle and see if it is more than 79 pips it is 102 pips i need this
candle to be between one atr and two atr in this case the atr of our candle is roughly 80 pips so
i would need this candle to be between 80 and 160 pips if it's more than 160 does not count if it's
80 it does not count if it's between the two if it's between one and two atr then i use this candle
as an entry for a false breakout situation what does that mean that means at the close of this
candle if it meets all of those requirements i would have an entry at the close of this candle
because it is a breakout candle from a previous swing low that is between one and two atr it's
它不是1ATR而不是2ATR
所以我有一些人的 entry
我讨论了一些人的投票
我讨论了1ATR
是1ATR
是1ATR的
1ATR的位置
这会是1ATR
所以我的投票是79PPS
1ATR的位置
我们做了一种投票的投票
我们有个人的投票
那一塊錢
我不知道為什麼這些東西都會變成很大
我想我會移動了
我們現在有一個停留下的停留下
1ATR下的停留下
我們有11pips在79pips
那一塊停留下的停留下
我們會有停留下的停留下
我們會把停留下的停留下
供我們的規定
我們在一個停留下的停留下
我剛才 showed你在這個影片
I just used a 1 to 1 target.
That's what produced since 2018 right at a 65% winning percentage was having a 1 to 1 target.
But as you can see, sometimes these false breakouts can provide a large, a massive risk to reward ratio.
So that's the power of this strategy and that's a brief version of how to actually do it.
Let's take a look at a couple of the trades over on the dollar Canada back test and then I'll let you guys go.
But first off, let's take a look at a couple of those so you can get a better idea of this strategy
to make sure you completely understand it main goal here being that you are capable of actually
testing this strategy yourself before i come out with the next video that explains it completely
so hopefully this will give you an idea of exactly what you need to be testing for
here we have our swing low looking left right here we have a breakout candle of that swing low
right here what do we need to check for next next we need to know is this breakout candle between
1 and 2ATR of this candle this candle has an ATR of 91 pips so we need to measure this candle
from high to low from high to low on our entry candle we have a 110 pip candle that means this
candle is between 1 and 2ATR because it needs to be more than 90 and less than 180 so therefore we
would be buying this breakout candle looking at it as a possible false breakout that would look
估计是这个换销售的戴上 这个课股的戴上
那个戴上的戴上的戴上的戴上是91批的
所以我们会有91批的,31批的博物
122批的戴上的戴上
这件不被划得到
就是在这一招的戴上的戴上
但是你能看到,有很多价值的戴上
我还没有试试,但是这一招是流量的戴上
这个是这个方法我现在正在工作用这个ATR指定
是一个可能性的一个状态
去讨论这些法律
所以你能够试一下这个方法
如果您是多多领域的方法
更多领域的方法
也就是这样的方法
但是更多领域的方法
我们有一个公式的方法
叫做EAP的方法
在那里面的方法
你会收到所有的方法
我自己用的方法
你会收到3-5的货币我将会收到每个月
你会收到几个月的货币
你会问我什么问题
我会有什么问题
在这个课程中是一个人的货币
所以我会有一个人的货币
我们现在有个人的货币
我会有些新的货币
我会有什么新的货币
我会有什么货币的货币
我会有什么货币
你会有什么货币
你会有关注的货币
請按 Like button,按 Like, for me to help out with the YouTube algorithm
I'm gonna put a video somewhere on the screen
You'll see it beside my face that I think would also be helpful to you on your trading journey
Make sure you follow in all of your rules in your trading plan
Make sure you're not risking too much in times like these
Put good use to your newly learned skill of understanding this ATR indicator in order to avoid being stopped out just by a little bit before
Hitting what could be massive targets?
I hope this has been helpful and I will talk to you in the next video.
See you soon.